what is your advice for like absolutely
zero to roof over your head it's the
reason I started making garage sale
videos right now in America the quickest
way to go from $20 to 10,000 I genuinely
leave is thrift stores and garage sales
because it's a place where you can buy
things for a quarter 50 cents in a
dollar and get 20 you can't do that in
many other places yeah but if you're
starting out at a thrift store on
Melrose no that's no [__] way that's
that's bougie thrift store I'm talking
Goodwill these are like brick and mortar
places where you can go and purchase
something for 50 cents a dollar and then
then you take it online and you you've
got such an infinitely larger audience
and it's not even your audience for was
listening say [__] I don't have an
audience no no no you just listed on
eBay you just lift it on Poshmark
there's all these places now I think
about this a lot because just started
getting enough emails saying like yo bro
I don't have $25,000 to put in some sort
of startup so what do I do I was like
[__] they're right I got to talk about
some other [__] and that's how I got to
this